kinsa chata volcano last erupted only a
few thousand years ago
[Music]
this is pumice organic rock ahead for
the summit with Peruvian archaeologist
Amelia Perez to hue
we follow the flow of lava
we're meeting my lidar team at the top
I'm looking for evidence that this was a
sacred site for people who are here
before the Inca
you guys ready to fly just about yet
okay ropes up
[Applause]
[Music]
these are all troopers right here just
over that edge there is aa spiritual
path frankerz jak se en el volcán these
suggest that people were burying their
ancestors close to a god-like event a
pal la gente de venir Romero cool palapa
selves all come in Segundo as the
answers offer endless bassoon sitios
equally su sitio importancia dentro de
sitio Lohia ring
you can imagine that when interrupted it
must have sent wonder or just disbelief
and in the minds of the people all
around it whatever material I share all
the material that way towards the city
exactamente hasta la parte de abajo
incredible the lava stretches for over a
mile at its base is a small town called
rec G
[Music]
these must be the man-made structures
that I could see on the satellite
imagery la gente que venía integrin ah
hey en determinar SI polka Sokka se
quedan en esto se spices this whole area
all of these were homes of people that
existed hundreds of years before the
Inca sea and they built their homes next
to a volcano amazing but pre inca
pilgrims weren't the only ones to have
left their mark here
[Music]
it's incredible
s impresionante news
Desna construction in Qatar owes a
construido sobre un spacy oz2 al aleppo
katrinka a la construction mas grande y
más alta durante la poka-yoke
amazing was it for as a temple de vida
coach at 40 I have a document that I
found from the Spanish chronicles see it
says when the Inca ruler passed by this
area he saw the shrine a Vedic culture
the people to hold him the miracle of
fire that fell from the sky he decided
that the remembrance should be greater
and ordered the erection of a large
building this was done and there was no
larger building in the lands of the
inkpad kind of sends shivers up your
spine and when you read something that
was written you know in 1557 and you're
standing here looking at it still
standing today Mira kocha era uno de sus
das principales de todo el hecho capri
un cadeau al quad-a indian cult era
prácticamente dama Vangelis adore el
salvador there seems to be a pattern
emerging the inca incorporate aspects of
earlier belief systems and make them
theirs by building bigger and better
this is architecture of power just like
at Machu Picchu
[Music]